- [Instructor] In previous
lessons, we've talked about
how polls and surveys are used
to measure public opinion,
but the important thing to recognize
is that they are estimates
of public opinion.
Ideally, they're done as
scientifically as possible,
as statistically robust as
possible, but even then,
they might not give an accurate picture.
And perhaps one of the most
famous recent examples of that
is the 2016 election.
In this chart, which I got
from Real Clear Politics,
you have the results of many of the polls
of Monday, November 7, 2016.
You might recognize that as the day before
the 2016 presidential election.
And if you were to just look at this chart
from the day before the
presidential election,
who would you think
would win the presidency?
As you can see, most of these polls
have Hillary Clinton having more support
among likely voters than Donald Trump,
but we know what happened on election day.
Donald Trump won the election.
Why did that happen?
Well, there's a lot of potential theories,
and political pundits continue to debate
why this happened.
One idea is that polls, when
they randomly sample people,
they're trying to randomly
sample likely voters.
And some people theorize that
there might have been a group
that voted in this election
that the pollsters did
not view as likely voters
but they voted nonetheless,
and amongst that group,
they voted disproportionately Trump.
Another idea is that
maybe someone else about
the sampling techniques
wasn't completely random,
that for some reason, it might have skewed
in favor of people who
leaned towards Clinton
instead of people who
leaned towards Trump.
Another idea is that these
are national poll results,
while we elect our president
through the electoral college.
So it might be more interesting to look at
especially some of the swing
states what were happening,
but even there, it was a surprise
for most political pundits
in terms of who won many of those states.
So the big picture here is
is that polls and surveys
can be valuable.
They can start to paint a picture of
where the public's views on things are,
but you should not view
them as indisputable truth.
They are samples from the population,
and it is hard to do a truly
random, unbiased sample.
And even when you do that,
you're not even sure if
people are going to tell you
who they're really going to vote for.
And even if they do tell the truth
of who they're thinking for
voting for at the moment,
we don't know.
Maybe their minds change by the time
they actually go to vote.